cette semaine on m'a proposé d'aller à
roland garros pour voir un match
franchement j'y serai bien les ans
si le tennis n'était pas le sport que je
déteste le plus pensez pas que je
déteste le tennis c'est juste que j'y
comprends rien pourtant parfois je me
force 7 6 7 4 6 6 0 5e set 5 3 0 40
trois balles de break second service
elle valait mieux dire qu'il faut un bac
+4 en tennis pour comprendre quelque
chose
et si le système de points n'est pas
assez compliqué pour toi tu marques tu
gagnes pas un mais 15 points pourquoi 15
je ne sais pas tu marques à nouveau
satan fait 30 plus après tu en gagnes
que 10 mystère absolu et si l'adversaire
galice a fait pas 40 partout mais 40 à
genre 40a
d'accord il égalise c'est pourquoi ceci
est incompréhensible que tu vas être
content parce que les mecs sur le
terrain sont aussi des grands mystères
de l'univers et de mec à côté du filet
par exemple les mecs ils sont là comme
ça pour le long du match
un jeu je sais pas c'est déstabilisant
d'avoir un mec dans une position bizarre
pendant que tu joues quoi parce que
c'est que pendant le match
[Musique]
bon j'avoue aussi si j'aime pas le
tennis c'est parce que je n'aime pas
faire du sport je crois que je crois que
ça se voit bon vous voilà et j'aime
encore moins les sports de balle pour
écouter les mains que soient les gentils
je n'aime pas trop les sports je vous
interdis de rigoler ça fait super mal
je crois que j'ai perdu la vue des
neiges
j'ai donc essayé un petit peu le tennis
parce qu'on m'a dit ouais vas-y fais du
sport pour tes muscles et un petit peu
fait du tennis qui a envie de faire un
sport qui te muscles une seule partie de
ton corps franchement de verizon le
tennis et pachon bien je me sens
beaucoup mieux dans mon corps je suis
complètement asymétrique je ressemble à
la picasso
bon ok ok d'accord d'accord en vrai je
regarde le tennis féminin en fermant les
yeux partager ma vidéo sur
facebook et rejoignez mappage ma page ça
me fait super plaisir aujourd'hui c'est
mon anniversaire vous plaît à la sortie
pour lepoint fr pour voir trop de
fausses vidéos
bon d'accord c'est pas mon amour sergent
[Musique]
le sopalin le meilleur ami de l'homme